what state did you have the Xbox in
um Arizona that's where I originally
bought it I bought in Arizona but it
traveled me all the way to Mississippi
and Mississippi when I came back I left
it to the homies you know so when you go
to those out of state places uh
there's a California politics Follow You
Hell Yeah mandatory we open up the
prison so we got to establish that right
just to avoid like look there's a
misconception of prison politics you
know like I know a lot of people have
come here and like try and make it sound
like it's a racial thing to be honest
with you like that's farthest from the
truth you know and my homeboy will tell
you like he was with me on the yard like
right we're doing everything together
but
it's a necessary evil in prison bro like
you gotta understand right let's say me
and you are on some thorough hood [ __ ]
right and we're in prison you know
there's a gang of smokers that are there
with us you know not it's not just
thorough foods that go to prison and you
know there's also crack kids there's
also dummies drunks right all kinds of
[ __ ] right
now when you're dealing with those type
of individuals they don't know the
structure that we know right like
respect right they don't know how to
like move accordingly so the prison
politics are a necessary evil to stop
race racial issues to real escalating
you know what I'm saying like hey that's
the phone for your people that's the
shower for your people that's the
basketball court for you guys so guess
what you'll never gotta fight with
somebody over hey I got next game and
it's a different race and then [ __ ]
we're all going to the hole you know
what I'm saying or it's it's kind of
like necessary to keep as much Harmony
as possible until there's not Harmony
until there's not right you know what
I'm saying but but it's not it's not
because oh we hate them nah it's not
even like that bro it's just to keep a
structure because you're in chaos all
the time I don't know bro I remember
when I would land to prisons right like
when you first get off the bus no
[ __ ] I remember when I got to
Centinel the three yard and I landed in
the lifer building
um because I was on close custody
because I had so much time so when
you're in close custody the first 15
years of your of your term you only get
two hours of program a day that's the
only time you get to come out so it's
two hours wow so I was in close custody
pretty much solitary
yeah so um
so I land on the life for billion to be
on close custody and I sat on the bench
and this Asian dude's [ __ ] yelling at
me from the door like welcome to Santa
hella because the prison is called
Centinela you know but like
there's no like how can you say it don't
let there's no there's no chance to ever
like think peacefully there you know
even if you're on your own peaceful
Journey like the noises around you are
always chaos oh they're always yeah yeah
somebody's always stirring the pop bro
it doesn't matter there's an idiot in
there yeah always somebody discouraging
you always like even when you're trying
to go home like what you getting ready
to go home for you just gonna come back
like what the [ __ ] they ain't going
[ __ ] mad you know what I'm
saying so so it's like all that rules
and all the structure is to create some
kind of normality you know what I'm
saying